♪ I'm like money in the bag ♪
♪ Yeah, girl... ♪
The beginning of season four
starts with Issa
on her self-care,
self-improvement tick.
BOTH:
Self-care Sunday!
ISSA RAE: She is excited
about this block party
that she's about to throw.
She's all about good vibes only.
It's a whole new world.
I'm Jasmine.
YVONNE ORJI: This whole season
is all about all four of us
trying to figure out
what serves us.
In our friendships
and our relationships.
I think the four ladies
as a whole,
they've grown individually
in different directions.
That's adulting.
It sucks.
NATASHA ROTHWELL:
This season is about becoming
their best selves,
individually,
and as friends.
You still wanna do this
though, right?
-You want to?
-Yeah, I want to.
(HIGH-PITCHED) Okay.
When I think about season four,
I think the most exciting thing
is Lawrence.
-(STAMMERS)
-(CHUCKLES)
Nah, I think, uh,
Lawrence and Issa
have a friendship,
but now they have
a common person in their life,
Condola,
which is who Lawrence
is now dating,
who happens to be friends
and working on a project
with Issa.
What?
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
♪ Tell these boys
To come outside ♪
-(HUMMING)
-(SCATTING)
I think our fans have
for sure missed us.
I'm ready for them to see
what we've been up to.
Season four of Insecure
is gonna be a wild ride.
Must-watch television.
A journey, honey.
It's gonna be nasty.
I love this season so much.
We were really excited
to be able to do 10 episodes
this time around.
But please just stop asking
for an hour.
It's a half-hour comedy
on HBO.
That's literally
just in the description.
So, I hope you enjoy them,
and I'm happy to be back.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪